♪ ♪
>> Dan: WELCOME BACK TO A
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
DESPITE THE HOROWITZ FINDINGS,
IN DETAIL, THE FISA, A
CONGENITAL LAYER CORRUPT
ADAM SCHIFF WITH NO REMORSE BUT
A YEAR'S WORTH LONG PHOT AND
SPREADING FISA LIES.
TAKE A LOOK.
CARTER PAGE SAYS THAT THE FBI
SPYING INTO HIS LIFE ON HIS GOOD
NAME.
HE ALSO SAYS THAT HE WILL "NEVER
COMPLETELY HAVE HIS NAME
RESTORED."
DO YOU FEEL ANY SYMPATHY FOR
CARTER PAGE?
>> I HAVE TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
CARTER PAGE CAME BEFORE OUR
COMMITTEE, AND FOUR HOURS OF
TESTIMONY, DENIED THINGS THAT WE
KNEW WERE TRUE AND LATER HAD TO
ADMIT THEM DURING HIS TESTIMONY.
IT'S ALSO HARD TO BE SYMPATHETIC
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO
ADMITTED TO BEING AN ADVISOR TO
THE KREMLIN.
>> BUT ALSO HE WAS INFORMING THE
CIA.
>> YES, YES.
>> WHICH WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT.
>> Dan: INCREDIBLE, REALLY.
CARTER PAGE WAS SMEARED FOUR
YEARS, ACCUSED OF BEING A
TRAITOR, ALL BASED ON LIES,
INNUENDO AND A PHONY DOSSIER.
AND ADAM SCHIFF DOESN'T HAVE TO
THE GUTS TO SHOW A LITTLE
REMORSE AND ADMIT HE'S WRONG?
THE SAME LAYER, THE NOW DEFUNCT
FISA MEMO IN THE GREEN LIGHT TO
RENT THE WITCH HUNT.
HE IS CORRUPT TO THE CORE.
IT IS UNDENIABLE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE BOOMERANG
OF JUSTICE IS IN FULL SWING.
NOT ONLY IS JOHN DURHAM HONING
IN ON THE ACTIONS OF EX-CIA
JOHN BRENNAN BUT ACCORDING TO A
NEW REPORT IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," DURHAM GOT
INTO A "SHARP DISPUTE OVER DRAFT
NOTE IN THE HOROWITZ REPORT AND
FOLLOW THE IG'S CONCLUSION,
INCLUDING POLITICAL BIAS.
NOW THE FOOTNOTE DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE FINAL REPORT SO
DURHAM IS UNCOVERING CONVINCING
EVIDENCE TO THE CLAPPER TO
BRENNAN.
AMERICA'S MOST POPULAR DEMOCRATS
ABUSE POWER TO TRY TO UNDO THE
RESULT OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
AND THE TIME FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
IS NOW.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK POWER GRAB,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JASON
CHAFFETZ WITH AUTHOR OF THE
GREAT BOOK "WITCH HUNT"
GREGG JARRETT AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER SOLOMON WHO I HAVE COME
TO RELY ON EXTENSIVELY.
I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST.
THIS THING THAT CARTER PAGE,
GREG, AN ABOMINATION AND NOT
HYPERBOLE.
YOU HAVE A NAVAL ACADEMY A
GRADUATE NOT CHARGED WITH ANY
CRIME WHO IS ACTUALLY DOING WORK
NOW WE KNOW FOR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY, CIA TO NAIL RUSSIANS
WORKING IN THIS COUNTRY TO HURT
THIS COUNTRY.
THE FBI THEN TARGETS THE SKY AND
MANIPULATES THE EMAIL AND
SUGGEST CONTACTS WITH HEAD
RUSSIANS WERE ON BEHALF OF
NEFARIOUS TREASONOUS ACTS.
I MEAN, THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
DISGUSTING MALFEASANCE I'VE EVER
SEEN.
>> JAMES KNEW IT BECAUSE THE
FIRST 30 STARTED TO ADHERE LATE
2016 IDENTIFYING CARTER PAGE,
PAGE SENDS A LETTER TO COMEY
SAYING IT'S NOT TRUE.
I'VE BEEN HELPING THE CIA.
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN
WITH YOU BUT COMEY IGNORED THE
LETTER AND SOFT A FISA WARRANT.
BUT ADAM SCHIFF WAS THE FIRST
PUBLICLY ACCUSED CARTER PAGE OF
BEING A RUSSIAN SPY BEFORE THE
FISA THE WARRANT SITUATION.
AND YOU JUST PLAYED A CLIP OF
SCHIFF ACCUSING CARTER PAGE OF
LYING IN FRONT OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
COMPLETELY UNTRUE.
THE TESTIMONY WAS NOVEMBER 2ND,
2015.
I'VE READ IT A DOZEN TIMES AND
WHOLE PORTIONS ARE REPEATED IN
MY BOOK.
CARTER PAGE TOLD THE TRUTH.
IF IT WERE OTHERWISE, HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ACCUSED AND PROSECUTED
FOR PERJURY.
NO, ADAM SCHIFF CONTINUES TO
LIE.
AND I INVITE PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY
READ THE TRANSCRIPT THAT IS
ONLINE.
CARTER PAGE, NOT ONLY TELLS THE
TRUTH, BUT ADAM SCHIFF MAKES AN
ABSOLUTE FOOL OF HIMSELF BY
TRYING ON CROSS-EXAMINATION TO
GET CARTER PAGE TO ADMIT THAT
MERELY SHAKING THE HAND OF A
CRIMINAL OFFICIAL AND SAYING
HELLO IS SOMEHOW A HUB GOBBLE OF
A GRAND CONSPIRACY TO COMMIT A
TREASONOUS ACT AND SEALED THE
2,000 ELECTION, 2016 ELECTION.
ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS CONTORTED
AND TWISTED MIND MAY STILL
BELIEVE IT AND IT IS LUDICROUS.
>> IT IS A STAIN ON OUR COUNTRY.
I WILL GO TO YOU.
YOUR REPORTING HAS BEEN
SPECTACULAR.
I HAVE RELIED ON IT AND IT IS
GOOD TO SEE THE MEDIA WHO HAS
TRIED TO TARNISH YOUR
REPRESENTATION AND ARE STARTING
TO COME AROUND AND REALIZE YOU
WERE RIGHT THE WHOLE TIME.
THEY ARE STUBBORN.
I KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR INFORMATION
ON CALMLY BUT IT IS OBVIOUS THAT
COMEY LIED.
I SHARED A FOOTNOTE THIS WEEK,
3/23, CALL COMEY SAID DENTIST
3/23 MEETING, AND VERIFIED,
3/23 NOT ONLY INVESTIGATING BUT
SENDING FBI OVERSEAS TO
INVESTIGATE.
THIS GUY COME I MEAN, IT REALLY
HIS REPUTATION HAS GOT TO BE
FINISHED.
>> IT IS AND THE LIES HE TOLD
CONGRESS ARE REALLY SERIOUS
ISSUES.
FOR INSTANCE HE SAID AT
ONE POINT, I DID NOT KNOW
CARTER PAGE HAD BEEN OPENED UP
THE SPRING 2016.
ONE OF THE REVELATIONS IN THE IG
REPORT.
IN FACT, HE WAS IN A MEETING
WITH JAMES COMEY AND THEY TALKED
ABOUT IT.
SAME THING WITH BRUCE OHR, HE
DID NOT KNOW BRUCE OHR IN THE
BACK WAY, GETTING THE
INFORMATION.
AND FOOTNOTES THERE SAYING HE
WAS IN A MEETING WITH BRUCE OHR
BRUCE OHR.
JAMES COMEY HAS AN EDITION L AND
I THINK DURHAM ADVANCES THIS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, THERE IS
A HIGH WAY THAT THEY WILL
LOOK AT HIM FALSELY.
>> THAT WHOLE LAUNDERING SCHEME,
AND AGAIN, JUST ANOTHER LIE, A
BEVY OF COMEY LIES.
CONGRESSMAN JASON CHAFFETZ, ONE
THING THAT HAS BOTHERED ME, THE
MALFEASANCE AND FOR A LIVING.
BUT THEY SUGGEST THAT THE IG
REPORT SAYS THERE IS NO
POLITICAL BIAS.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE REPORT
SAID.
MATTER OF FACT, HOROWITZ OWN
WORDS IN FRONT OF THE SENATE
MEETING COME ALL THE WAY DIDN'T
FIND A DOCUMENT, YES, WE OPENED
UP ON TRUMP AND WE HATE HIM AND
IT'S POLITICALLY BIASED.
HE SAID ONE OF TWO THINGS, GROSS
NEGLIGENCE OR POLITICAL BIAS.
IT SHOWS YOU HOW THE MEDIA WILL
TAKE ANYTHING AND SPEND IT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS NARRATIVE.
>> AND ALSO WHAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL SAID, HE DID NOT LOOK AT
IT AND COULD NOT DEMONSTRATE
DEFINITIVELY ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER IF ANY BIAS WAS INJECTED
INTO ITSELF AND THE ACTUAL PHIS
APPLICATION.
WHAT HE SAID TO COME HE COULD
NOT FIND THE PRECEPT THAT HE HAD
DOCUMENTED ANY SORT OF BIAS AND
HE WAS THE SENIOR MOST PERSON TA
HE WAS THE SENIOR MOST PERSON TT
STARTED THIS OPERATION, BUT
THAT'S LIKE NOT EVEN A PAGE OF A
450 PAGE IG REPORT.
IF ANYBODY THINKS THEY WERE
EXONERATED WERE CLEARED, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
COMEY TAKES IT IN THE SHORTS FOR
THE FIFTH TIME IN OVER 1,000
PAGES NOW DOCUMENTED FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
SO GOOD LUCK WITH THAT,
MR. COMEY.
>> Dan: I WANT TO GET A QUICK
ANSWER, HOW MUCH TROUBLE DO YOU
THINK, GO TO YOU FIRST, GREGG,
JOHN BRENNAN IS IN.
THE REASON I ASK THE SWORN
TESTIMONY OF LISA PAGE, SHE
TELLS MARK MEADOWS UNDER OATH
THAT SHE WOULD BE GENUINELY
STUNNED IF THE CIA WAS GETTING
INFORMATION FROM
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
AND I'M NOT GIVING THE FBI A
PASS IF COMEY LIED THROUGHOUT
THIS WHOLE THING BUT IF THERE
WAS A PUPPETMASTER AND THIS FROM
THE INTEL SIDE IT MAY HAVE BEEN
JOHN BRENNAN.
>> WHY?
I CALL BRENNAN THE INSTIGATOR IN
MY BOOK.
HE CREATED BEFORE A
STEELE DOSSIER AND ENTER AGENCY
TASK FORCE THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
FOUNDATION, YOU KNOW THIS, JOHN,
WAS THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
TRUMP RUSSIA AND A HOAX.
SO I THINK BRENNAN HAS A LOT TO
ANSWER FOR.
AND I THINK DURHAM MAY BE
LOOKING AT FALSE STATEMENTS
FALSE STATEMENTS INSOFAR AS
BRENNAN IS CONCERNED.
>> GREGG HAS IT EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT IS ONE PLACE TO BE CRACKED
OPEN BY DURHAM.
AND ALSO THE ISSUE OF BIAS, THE
BIGGEST BIAS INJECTED INTO THE
INVESTIGATION WAS THE
STEELE DOSSIER.
HE ADMITTED HE WAS DESPERATE TO
MEET TRUMP AND THE FBI USED THAT
TO GO TO THE PFIZER
TO GO TO THE FFIZER
TO GO TO THE FISZER
TO GO TO THE FISA R
TO GO TO THE FISA COURT.
ALL OVER THIS, FISA.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMAN HOW MUCH
DO TROUBLE DO YOU THINK
JOHN BRENNAN IS IN HIM THIS?
>> HE'S IN A LOT OF TROUBLE, YOU
AGREE WITH THE OTHER TWO BUT I
WOULD ALSO SAY, DAN FOLLOW THE
MONEY.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT FLOW FROM THE DEMOCRATS
OVERSEAS AND DURHAM IS ABLE TO
GO LOOK AT THAT.
SOMETHING THAT HOROWITZ COULDN'T